und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend auch heute richtet sich der
blick erstmal aufs kroner geschehen in
deutschland so bald werden wir das thema
auch nicht los sorge bereiten die
mutierten viren aus großbritannien
südafrika oder brasilien die
brasilianische mutation wurde jetzt in
deutschland auch erstmals nachgewiesen
bei einer person die am donnerstag von
dort eingereist ist für auslandsreisen
aller art gelten ab heute übrigens teils
verschärfte regeln und neue einteilungen
von risikogebieten zu finden auf der
internetseite des robert koch instituts
die zahl der täglich neu gemeldeten
infektionen sinkt sie ist aber immer
noch hoch wie auch die zahl der toten
mehr als 50.000 sind insgesamt
inzwischen zu beklagen
andreas vortag berichtet ein licht dem
fenster eine aktion des
bundespräsidenten zum gedenken von heute
an sollen bürgerinnen und bürger so an
die toten der korona pandemie erinnert
wir sollten ein licht ins fenster
stellen als ein zeichen der solidarität
des mitgefühls in diesen dunklen zeiten
es wäre endlich licht in sachen corona
so die hoffnung die hoffnung auf ein
schnelles ende die style mediziner und
der bundesgesundheitsministerin ihrer
pandemie bewertung allerdings nicht
die zahlen entwickeln sich in die
richtige richtung aber sie sind immer
noch auf zu hohem niveau zusammenfassend
erkennen wir an den deutlich sinkenden
patientenzahlen auf der intensivstation
erste positive wirkung des aktuellen
lockdown aber wir sind noch weit weg von
einer situation in der man von einer
entspannung sprechen kann zu viel aber
zwar sinken die infektionen aber allein
die zahl der toten müsse mahnung genug
seien jetzt nicht voreilig zu lockern
insgesamt sind seit beginn der pandemie
50.000 642 menschen in verbindung mit 19
gestorben das sind die offiziellen
meldezahlen und das ist eine bedrückende
für mich schier unfassbare zur hoffnung
gibt dass impfen darauf setzen die
experten für sie ist dass das so oft
beschriebene licht am ende des tunnels
unser ziel ist es stand heute im sommer
geben der möchte ein impfangebot zu
machen und die pandemie zu überwinden
im schloss bellevue brennt das licht der
anteilnahme nach ostern will der
bundespräsident in einer zentralen
gedenkfeier an die toten der pandemie
erinnern
in den usa rechnet präsident biden damit
dass im februar die zahl der
cholera-toten eine halbe million
erreichen wird bei kronach maßnahmen
geht es dem amerikanischen präsidenten
übrigens nicht unähnlich wie der
deutschen kanzlerin
er hat in einem föderalen staat dann nur
begrenzt einfluss
das hat in der krise zum teil auch
geholfen weil einige der
us-bundesstaaten nicht den
einschätzungen von donald trump folgten
sondern sich selbst für shutdowns
entschieden
allerdings gab es dabei dann oft keine
unterstützung mehr aus waschechten auch
ist washington unter anderem zuständig
für die beschaffung und verteilung von
tests und impfstoffen und ähnlichem und
kann umfängliche finanzhilfen anbieten
das wird so beiden jetzt auch tun
berichtet benjamin daniel wo jetzt eines
der größten kalifornischen impfzentren
steht war früher eine riesige
einkaufsmall die ging aufgrund der
pandemie pleite wie so viele unternehmen
und betriebe in amerika auch deshalb
will die neue administration keine zeit
verlieren ihr hilfsprogramm für die
wirtschaft umzusetzen
durch die neue verordnung soll unter
anderem die finanzielle unterstützung
für die staaten erhöht werden um die
kosten zu decken für nationalgardisten
notfall equipment und den aufbau von
impfzentren außerdem will beiden 100
millionen impfungen in den ersten 100
tagen seiner präsidentschaft sehen dafür
hatte er einen rund 200 seiten dicken
aktionsplan vorgelegt
wir werden einen eigenen code 19
pandemie ausschuss einrichten der wird
sich intensiv mit dem thema testen
beschäftigen und sicherstellen dass die
kapazitäten vorhanden sind wo sie
gebraucht werden
der führende us virologe fauci gab früh
am morgen eine pressekonferenz
in jedem fall werden wir alles 100
prozent transparent machen offen und
ehrlich wenn mal etwas schief geht
zeigen wir nicht mit dem finger auf
jemanden aber korrigieren den fehler und
alles was wir tun wird auch
wissenschaftlicher grundlage entscheiden
während man im weißen haus heute nach
vorn blickt beschäftigte sich der
kongress auch mit der aufarbeitung der
vergangenheit zu teilten die spitzen der
demokraten im kongress mit dass das
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen donald
trump am montag in den senat
weitergeleitet wird
in den usa dem beobachter nicht wie viel
gelöster drv die plötzlich wirkte als
sei ihm eine schwere last von den
schultern genommen
donald trump hatte ihn übel mitgespielt
und stelle sich vor in deutschland würde
der leiter des robert koch instituts von
der bundeskanzlerin als idiot beschimpft
während sie selbst zugleich wirkungslose
medikamente empfiehlt oder über das
spritzen von diesen infektions mitteln
saniert all das ist unser traum
tatsächlich geschehen von den chrono
rannten in höchsten staatsämtern großer
nationen ist jetzt eigentlich nur noch
brasiliens ball szenario übrig dessen
konzeptionslose durchseuchung lassen hat
längst furchtbare folgen wir unser
korrespondent christoph rath berichtet
es ist hochsommer in rio und es sieht so
aus wie im aktuelle bilder
die strände sind voll das leben geht
weiter sagen die einen die anderen
begraben ihre toten so wie hier in sao
paulo oder sie betteln um einlass vor
den krankenhäusern wie in der
amazonasmetropole manaus wo sich die
zahl der täglichen todesfälle binnen
eines monats fast verzehnfacht hat ein
mann schnappt sterbend nach luft sein
sohn filmteam und fleht um hilfe an der
verschlossenen tür derzeit trauriger
alltag in manaus
die menschen sterben das ist kein spiel
das ist kein spiel
hilfe wo bleibt der sauerstoff für die
krankenhäuser zu wenige betten und kein
sauerstoff
mehrere patienten teilen sich eine
flasche und auf der straße warten
hunderte auf sauerstoff um ihre
angehörigen wenigstens zu hause
versorgen zu können
zudem wird aus manaus eine neue mutation
des virus gemeldet
noch ist nicht sicher wie gefährlich sie
ist aber für wissenschaftler ist sie die
folge des versagens der brasilianischen
regierung im umgang mit der pandemie
wenn man dem virus freien lauf lässt
dann führt das nicht nur zu einem
zusammenbruch des gesundheitssystems
mannschaft auch die perfekte umgebung
für mutationen präsident portion euro
hat die krankheit von anfang an
heruntergespielt und zuletzt sogar
stimmung gemacht gegen die nur
schleppend anlaufenden impfungen weil
seine regierung auch hier spät gehandelt
hat die folge die korona zahlen in
brasilien rasen nach oben und die
proteste gegen den präsidenten werden
wieder lauter und jetzt die nachrichten
von heinz wolf nachdem sich armin
laschet beim online parteitag als
kandidat für den cdu-vorsitz
durchgesetzt hat ist er auch in der
anschließenden briefwahl von den
delegierten für das amt bestätigt worden
flasche den vielen 83,3 5 prozent der
briefwahlstimmen verkündete der
wahlvorstand heute in berlin
damit ist die entscheidung des online
parteitags am vergangenen samstag
rechtskräftig bei dem sich laschet am
ende in einer stichwahl gegen friedrich
haas durchgesetzt hatte die afg klagt
vor dem verwaltungsgericht köln gegen
das dort ansässige bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz die partei hat zwei
klagen und zwei eilanträge eingereicht
darin beantragt die afg dem
verfassungsschutz zu verbieten sie als
verdachtsfall einzustufen und dies
öffentlich bekannt zu geben
eine gerichtssprecherin kündigte für
montag eine zwischenentscheidung an nach
medienberichten will das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz in der kommenden woche
eine entscheidung über den weiteren
umgang mit der afg treffen
vor dem landgericht leipzig hat der
prozess gegen einen ehemaligen
bundeswehr- soldaten der eliteeinheit
ksk begonnen
er soll unerlaubt waffen und sprengstoff
auf seinem grundstück gelagert haben zu
prozessbeginn äußerte sich der 45
jährige zu den vorwürfen er habe mit den
waffen seine soldaten bestmöglich
ausbilden wollen
bei einer razzia im vergangenen mai
waren neben waffen unter anderem auch
sprengstoff und mehrere tausend stück
munition entdeckt worden
mehr als ein jahr nach dem tod von 39
vietnamesen in großbritannien hat ein
gericht in london vier angeklagte männer
zu haftstrafen zwischen 13 und 27 jahren
verurteilt unter anderem wegen
menschenhandels und fahrlässiger tötung
ende oktober 2009 10 waren die 39
migranten tot in einem lkw nahe london
gefunden worden
sie sterben und sauerstoffmangel und
überhitzung zurück nach deutschland und
zu den wetteraussichten für morgen
von vorpommern bis nach oberbayern
regnet und schneit es vor allem am
vormittag zum teil kräftig auch im
südwesten kommt dann nachmittag regen
auf und schnee auch dazwischen bleibt es
meist trocken
die temperatur steigt auf werte von null
bis sieben grad und auch in den nächsten
tagen wird es winterlich mit schnee oft
bis ins flachland weiter die
höchsttemperaturen liegen zwischen minus
zwei und plus vier grad
ja das wasser stand von uns und um 0.15
gibt es an unserer heutigen update mit
hanna zimmermann auf wiedersehen wieder
sinn
[Musik]